and well you mentioned killing is being
up for the most Awards tonight nominated
for five and I'm joined by the woman of
the hour David congratulations firstly I
mean it was a show that just everyone
was talking about last year what did you
make the reaction I mean it was
incredible I think we all believed in
the show and a tremendous one film in it
but you just never know what's gonna
resonate there's so much out there now
for people to watch so to see a kind of
spread like wildfire was M sink
reservoir China celebrates did you in
particular have a lot of fun with this
role she seems like a carrot to me in
yes
I live everything through her it's so
good because I get to express so much
much through her and she gets away with
so much mischief and naughtiness that I
never would get away with but was also
you know deeply kind of dangerous and
and equally as terrifying so it's a do
you find her terrifying or do you think
she's just misunderstood I'd be like I
really defend her which is really
probably terrible but I guess I have to
play here I have to excuse her but it's
just honest to god this just so much fun
every day on set is so different and
she said that and we're all very excited
because the leading actress category
you're going up against Sandro yes have
you spoken about this rivalry yeah no I
don't feel it in these and it's not the
fact that we're in the same category
shows that we haven't to female
protagonist yeah this is a good problem
to have you know and and we champion
each other equally as much and then so
this is a really privileged position to
being in TK much we're following on from
killing even five Awards up with in the
running after dies The Bodyguard was
three also a very English scandal which
is nominated for four so he knows
whether or not killing he was going to
be the one which walks away with all the
words tonight certainly I think
critically everyone has been loosing
really for killing ink because it is the
one that has got so many people talking
last year